2022 was a year of weather Extremes in
the UK likely according to the Met
Office to have been the warmest on
record
it meant heat waves and destructive
wildfires
and a punishing drought that sucked the
life out of rivers and lakes
there were powerful storms too and
widespread flooding that followed
at the end of the year bought a cold
snap and a deep freeze not all of this
was driven by climate change but much of
it was we can't tackle and adapt to
climate change without restoring nature
now the National Trust is warning that
what could be the new normal presents a
real challenge for our natural world
they've had a really tough year and
we've seen whole grassland Landscapes
like places like it around Stonehenge
where the grass and the flowers have
just died back very prematurely and that
of course has knock-on impacts on things
like the pollinators like butterflies
and bumblebees which are reliant on
those plants you're losing habitat and
food sources for the Wildlife and so it
Cascades down these ecosystems among the
species that suffered were bats who
couldn't cope with the extra heat
some butterflies and other flying
insects struggled too as habitats were
impacted by the drought
on top of this a virulent strain of bird
flu devastated seabird colonies despite
the mainly bad news for nature a few
success stories have also emerged with
some wildlife and habitat showing that
with a little assistance they can adapt
well to the new conditions
that includes these beavers benefiting
from a project to protect their wet
woodland habitat in Somerset
and these chuffs are slowly starting to
thrive in Cornwall after successful
efforts to protect them
the natural world demonstrating both its
fragility and resilience as our weather
becomes more unpredictable and extreme
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News